economía en france 24 está conmigo en el
estudio daniel hablando con daniela muy
buenas noches en qué consiste este
fenómeno game stop que hizo temblar esta
semana a wall street
santiago buenas noches mire hay una red
social que se llama red it y en uno de
sus foros 'wall street' pet participan
miles de pequeños inversionistas
aficionados que no tienen el expertise
que sí tienen los veteranos de la bolsa
de nueva york pero aún así lograron
sacar jugosas ganancias a costa de una
empresa llamada gamestop esta es una
tienda de videojuegos con varios locales
en centros comerciales pero con la
pandemia y la migración hacia los
videojuegos online resulta poco
atractiva en bolsa los grandes
inversionistas vieron la opción de ganar
dinero a partir de especular con esta
acción baja y estos pequeños traders
encontraron la manera de hacerlos perder
como lo hicieron nos lo cuenta un
catedrático
qué sucedió durante el día de ayer se ha
corrido de la semana con esta compañía
por lo que el precio de la acción en
esta campaña pues que a través de la
plataforma que mencionaba sobre la red
social que mencionabas y concretamente a
través de ese subgrupo que tiene
alrededor de tres millones de usuarios
estos pequeños inversionistas a través
de diferentes plataformas web de
especulación que hoy en día proliferan
por qué estado toda una jugada de compra
masiva de la acción generaron una
sobredemanda de la acción en el corto
plazo y esto generó un incremento en el
corto plazo de la acción y generó en el
corto plazo en las pérdidas muy
importantes para estos gestos fons en
efecto de ser una empresa por la que
nadie daba un centavo hace un par de
semanas
gamestop pasó de costar 17 dólares a
comienzos de año a un pico de 347
dólares hace apenas dos días es un plata
blanca santiago santiago quiere decir
que pasó de costar mil millones de
dólares a 13 mil 500 millones de dólares
el tema ha sido tan polémico que
del mercado ya dijo que lo va a analizar
y la misma casa blanca tuvo que hacer lo
propio pues analizar ya ver los
resultados y seguramente usted aquí no
los va a contar
daniela el mundo se endeudó en el 2020
tanto igual o más como en la segunda
guerra mundial así es el fondo
monetariointernacional actualizó este
jueves su reporte de sostenibilidad
fiscal la conclusión es que la deuda
pública del mundo es casi igual al
producto interno bruto es decir a lo que
producen en bienes y servicios todos los
países en promedio este nivel de
endeudamiento del 98 por ciento del pib
no se veía desde hace dos décadas desde
hace décadas y antes de la pandemia era
del 84 por ciento además es un promedio
por lo que hay países que pueden estar
muy por encima de esa proporción por eso
el organismo pidió a los gobiernos
aprovechar la crisis para repensar sus
reglas y sus marcos fiscales hablemos
ahora de la economía de eeuu que sufrió
su mayor caída en casi ocho décadas en
2020 tuvo una contracción del 3.5 por
ciento a pesar de haber logrado un
aumento trimestral del 4 por ciento
entre
octubre y diciembre ni siquiera la
reserva federal se lo esperaba pues
ellos preveían una caída del 27 % ni en
la crisis de 2008 y 2009 el de eeuu
llegó a caer tanto por lo que el de
ahora es el peor registro del que se
tiene noticia desde el fin de la segunda
guerra mundial hace 74 años cuando se
desplomó en más del 12 por ciento como
vemos en la gráfica el futuro es muy
incierto porque todavía hay casi 10
millones de ciudadanos sin empleo
hablemos ahora de la venta de oro a
nivel mundial que en este primer año de
pandemia kobe 19 se vendió mucho menos
oro que en otros años pues la pandemia
del códido de 19 hizo que la demanda
mundial de este metal precioso cayera un
14 por ciento en 2020 hasta las 3 mil
700 toneladas esto es un nivel más bajo
en 11 años según datos publicados por el
consejo mundial del oro el informe dice
que las joyerías fueron las más
afectadas la caída de sus pedidos llegó
a ser del 34 por ciento lo que sí subió
fue la inversión en oro en la bolsa en
un 40 por ciento esto porque el oro es
un llamado activo refugio que es
mucho más seguro cuando hay
incertidumbre en el resto del mercado
hablemos ahora de los indicadores como
las fue las principales bolsas en la
forma wall street del cerro con
ganancias en un rebote desde la peor
jornada que había tenido en tres meses
debido al fenómeno justamente de
gamestop y a los resultados trimestrales
de algunas empresas en europa los
mercados subieron alentados por mejores
datos de empleo en eeuu con excepción de
londres y en américa latina la bolsa de
sao paulo interrumpió una racha de seis
jornadas en rojo es todo por el momento
daniela muchas gracias por esta
actualización aquí del mundo de la
economía ustedes gracias por la sintonía
sigan con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]
i